[Musica]
prigioniera numero 18 05 1972
incarcerata da quando è nata sono stati
uccisi tutti i suoi figli
lei stessa condannata a morte nel
momento nel quale è stata ritenuta
inutile
il suo nome era marta
prigioniera 100 276
incatenata da quando è nata sono stati
uccisi tutti i suoi figli
alle sue mammelle per anni attaccate
delle pompe idrauliche
condannata a morte nel momento nel quale
è stata ritenuta inutile
il suo nome era marta
sono due
madri tra le 60 mila madri e sono state
uccise
a quando ho cominciato questo discorso
60.000
l'uomo giustifica questo
olocausto
definendolo un processo naturale
necessario normale
perché nella nostra cultura occidentale
questi sono semplicemente degli anonimi
animali di allevamento sono nati per
soffrire per essere uccisi per nutrirci
vale però la pena ricordare che
questa è la primaria a causa di
distruzione di questo pianeta
inquinamento cambio climatico
distruzione delle risorse naturali
vale la pena
inoltre
sapere che la metà del cipro prodotto in
questa maniera è gettato via procediamo
ogni anno miliardi di animali non per
sfamare i popoli che muoiono di fame
bensì per buttarli nella pattumiera
senza contare poi il fatto che grazie a
questa alimentazione sono milioni di
persone che soffrono di malattie
obesità diabete ed altre forme di
malattia relazionate direttamente a
questo tipo di alimentazione
ciò nonostante io non sono qui oggi per
definire come possiamo e dobbiamo
nutrire 8 miliardi di umani
io qui oggi sono per parlare degli
innocenti che non possono farlo al posto
loro
come max
come john
come mike come albert come tami
come la berta ed infine come frederic
e non hanno nulla a che vedere con la
nostra alimentazione
la fanno parte dei milioni di animali
che noi procediamo per le loro pellicce
per le nostre ricerche scientifiche per
il nostro divertimento
o semplicemente per l'incuranza che
abbiamo verso la natura
questi non sono animali
queste sono persone
sì perché il termine persona da un punto
di vista giuridico non ha nulla a che
vedere con il termine umano che
rappresenta il genere della specie
sapiens sapiens dell'ordine dei primati
della classe dei mammiferi alla quale
noi apparteniamo
da un punto di vista giuridico
la persona è un'entità senziente capace
di provare emozioni complesse come
l'amore e la compassione
da un punto di vista giuridico la
persona è colui o colei che prende
decisioni autonome della propria vita a
un passato vive nel presente e ha un
futuro
la persona desidera vivere
e desidera a mare
come desideravano vivere amare marta e
emma
sorprendentemente nella storia lo stato
di persona è stato negato anche agli
esseri umani
per millenni l'uomo bianco
ha negato questo stato all'uomo nero
schiavizzando e uccidendo milioni di
uomini neri
e grazie alle guerre che abbiamo
sconfitto questa piaga sociale chiamata
schiavitù
poi abbiamo ritenuto legittimo limitare
loro i diritti civili
e siamo in parte riusciti anche a
sconfiggere la seconda piaga sociale
chiamata razzismo
e nella forma più criminale meschina
della storia ha ucciso sei milioni di
ebrei sotto la forma del nazismo
abbiamo anche inteso che la donna non è
affatto inferiore all'uomo maschio è
oggigiorno nessuno veramente può
accogliere un consenso sociale
promuovendosi con discorsi maschilisti
questa piaga si chiama sessismo
pertanto l'idea che la specie umana sia
superiore a tutto il creato e anche lei
una visione distorta della realtà si
chiama specismo e rappresenta forse la
più grande conquista sociale che
possiamo abbracciare nei prossimi
decenni
l'idea che l'uomo sia superiore contro
la natura è una visione alienata di noi
stessi
noi non siamo questi mostri che
distruggono il pianeta terra
noi siamo gli dei di questo pianeta e
come tali dobbiamo comportarci
non è possibile parlare oggi di
industria 4.0
intelligenza artificiale
realtà virtuale genetica nanotecnologie
robotica e basare ancora il nostro
benessere sociale ed economico sulla
distruzione della vita dei più deboli
non si tratta neanche di
creare generare noi un senso di colpa
questo è un viaggio che non finisce mai
quello di prendere coscienza del reale
potere dell'uomo
ci troviamo di fronte alla possibilità
di trascendere i nostri limiti perché
quando capiremo
che noi siamo parte del creato e siamo i
suoi difensori
probabilmente sapremo ancora di più che
cosa vuol dire l'essenza dell'essere
umano e del suo potere
sono cosciente del fatto che siano molte
persone che sono apertamente ostili a
questa visione liberale dei diritti
dell'uomo e degli animali
e delle piante
e allora non posso far altro
e chiederlo in ginocchio
abbiate misericordia di questo mondo
perché senza di voi non
lo salveremo mai
la infrastruttura di questo mondo sono i
cuori delle persone
la chiave di svolta che stiamo cercando
si trova solo ed esclusivamente dentro
ciascuno di noi
solo ed esclusivamente agendo insieme
apriremo la porta del nostro futuro
grazie della vostra attenzione
[Applauso]